Culture is everywhere. From every human
background, there is culture that they
have been born into. But we have to be
real about something. I think it's about
time. In our place in time in history,
we are approaching a time where we have
to be very serious about who we are,
what we've been doing, and where we need
to be better for Christ in our lives.
Now, some things that I have found out,
which is today's show, is that culture
is and never has been neutral. It is not
a benign thing. In other words, it has
motive. It was intentional. And I'll
show you why andor how.
>> Candy truth.
>> To begin, we see throughout history that
dominant powers have always used culture
to shape the way people think. In the
Mayan cultures, it was to get praise
from the people and get them to be able
to do a lot of things to the gods to
have power. As we see, culture usually
has ingrained in it. And I would like
for people to stop using culture as an
excuse for things to continue.
Pedophilia, rape, and incest might be a
part of culture. You can't just say,
"Well, it's been our tradition. It's
been our culture all these years. We
must continue worshiping idols or
animals or even stones and crystals and
rocks and trees. Mother Earth, it
doesn't matter if that has been part of
your culture in the past. It cannot just
be justified like that. Now, God even
calls us out of sorcery, divination,
fortunetelling, necromancy. All of these
things are also found as culture in some
of our backgrounds. things that are
practiced in that culture, from those
towns, even in your families, Santa Cia
perhaps. We have to get away from these
things. The Bible calls us out. And
unfortunately, even for myself and for
everyone on planet Earth, there's a
truth that I'm about to show you about
culture in general. As I said, it's a
tool and it's been used to shape the way
people think, believe, and behave. What
I found is that this shaping is not
organic. If you leave people alone to do
natural living, culture doesn't just
naturally shape itself this way. It
starts borrowing from other cultures,
ancient languages, and others around
them and even occult traditions to embed
hidden meanings and values into
entertainment, sports, education,
fashion, and media. This is what those
dominating powers of the government or
in this world have done. That's the way
that they have used it. Satan likes to
go ahead and make others compare and
start to have these same vices and
violations towards God. When he said,
"Do not do these things. Do not worship
idols. Do not fornicate or marry foreign
people who have these heathen ways," he
meant it. He had a reason for all of
this. He told us why. Do not do this.
because it was for us to remain pure,
his people spiritually clean, continuing
to not become a part of their habits,
practices, and festivals and so on, but
to remain pure in following him. So
without further ado, let's go into it
deeper. What we call pop culture is a
pipeline, a pipeline of a slow, subtle
indoctrination where the masses begin to
accept and normalize things that they
once, yes, once would have rejected. You
make it cool. You make it masked in
humor or team spirit or national spirit
and pride or any other kind of pride and
so on with addictions and substances all
attached to it. It doesn't make it okay.
Somehow although we know it's been used
against us in that way, just because
they're using it in a fun way does not
mean it is advocated for or blessed by
God. In fact, the more humor and the fun
that they can wrap into it, they realize
they can get past our frontal loes. Our
brains are not working properly, a lot
of stuff slips past us that we would
have actually paused and noticed as
wrong according to God's law if our
brain had been working at that moment.
But the key is that we do know. And if
you don't know that I'm telling you
these things are wrong. Once we know, we
can actually stop and go, just because
they laughed at that joke and it had
crude humor that was inappropriate does
not mean I should have laughed. You stop
yourself. Eventually, it becomes your
guide. God's law, if you want to be
Christian, becomes your guide as to how
to act and what your habits, what's your
hobbies, what you're putting in front of
your eyes, your ears, and even in your
mouth. It will tell you what that looks
like in a Christian's life. It is not
any of these things. However, I digress.
The point is that we do we give into
many things that we would not have. We
would have rejected them based on moral
standards that we know better. But
instead, we give into them based on pure
pressure, making it look fun, harmless,
and everything that Satan also uses to
get us hooked and participating. But
over time, this builds a shared mindset
of everyone rejecting common logic, if
you will, and morality together. in one
mindset that celebrates rebellion
against truth, glorifies self- worship,
and mocks what is holy. This is not
accidental, unfortunately. It's
intentional. And behind the scenes,
there are those who understand
symbolism, spiritual influence, and
psychological manipulation that have
used culture to cultivate, literally
cultivate the cult. Does this make
sense? Cult sure equals culture. It's a
worldwide system of thought that
prepares humanity to unite. What are we
looking for in the last days? We're
looking for people to unite in this
ecumenical, which means worldwide
message, a one world church, one world
government that runs the world in the
wrong way. For people to unite not under
truth, but under debauchery and sorcery
and the antichrist power, which is
deception. So, we're looking for this
very thing to happen in the last days.
But will some of us realize that it's
even happening? Do we realize? Stick
with me. Because, like I said, it's
uniting not around truth, but around
deception. It's the slow forming of the
one world cult masked as progress,
unity, and inclusivity. Don't we hear
that all the time? Be inclusive. But at
its core, it is about control. And we
know that, don't we? Getting everyone to
think the same, speak the same, and
ultimately worship the same false light.
And it's not a coincidence that they
call it programming. When we have
computer programming, television
programming, dreaming programming, it is
all designed to program your thinking
using repetition, using symbolism and
emotional manipulation. This is known as
social engineering where a calculated
effort to shape society's values,
desires, and beliefs are predetermined
direction. In other words, there are
men, whether it's Illuminati or the
elites, that are behind them, these
initiatives and the social engineering
programming these things and going,
"Yes, let's do this." They're almost
behind there pulling the strings,
flipping the switches, making it look
fun so that it can be followed and
directed in this way. Will we be
discerning enough to see it? So what
does when we truly look at it, what does
the word culture mean? When we get into
the ethmology of it, the Latin word
cultus, which we get from both cult and
culture, means care, cultivation,
worship or reverence or a deity. It
comes from the verb kolier or colery.
Maybe I'm not saying it right, but that
means to till cultivate, protect or
honor. So, in some ways, they are
getting us to cultivate the cult
protection and honor and reverence for a
deity of the wrong kind in our culture
today. That's what makes it culture.
Some of us might be coming with from our
different backgrounds with all kinds of
culture where it's becoming now a
melting pot of a American culture.
That's kind of like saying a coexist
movement is going on. We're trying to
accept every little thing Hinduism,
Buddhism, pantheism, and Christianity
all in one, which is their plan. That's
their thing they're trying to do that
we're warned against this unity coming.
That is not to be something we as true
Christians get wrapped up into. But
kolier told you what that meant.
Further, in ancient Rome, they have a
word that said that's called cultist
diorum meant the worship of the gods
through ritual, feast, and sacrifice. In
other words, culture and cult have
always been tied together to worship and
the shaping of thought through habitual
devotion to care for and reverence a
specific deity. So when we say culture,
we are witnessing modern-day cultists,
their rituals. Yes, we see those rituals
everywhere. The images and beliefs
people live by and often subconsciously
worship as well. We see it with their
idols. Like literally American idols,
their sports teams, celebrities, actors,
actresses. They have this. We have this
attached to every part of culture.
Culture has always been the rising up of
the cult hidden in plain sight. Further
proof that culture has always been
something that has been intentional come
straight from this man Joseph Gobles who
is Hitler's minister of propaganda. He
explicitly used culture as a tool which
is used today. He said, "We want to
cultivate obedience and unify the
population into a single ideological
cult. Use cinema, music, art, and
education to weaponize beauty and
emotion. Why? Because you can use that
against the people to get them drawn
into doing things they would not have
regularly done if they were using their
discernment, wisdom, having their
perception and being able to see that
many of these things that are wrong to
do are being cloaked in beauty, emotion,
and fun and pleasure. The goal to fuse
art with ideology and fuse people into a
hive mind. This was actually part of a
very conscious program, but it was the
Nazification of all social and cultural
institutions to ensure absolute
alignment with the state's worldview.
Isn't that amazing to all of a sudden
just have that stated by Hitler's
Minister of Propaganda. It's crazy.
Beyond propaganda, the Nazis, of course,
were steeped in the occult heavily. They
had groups like the Thu Society and the
Vril Society which combined pagan
mysticism, secret rituals and esoteric
symbols to craft their vision of a new
age, a golden era ruled by elite
knowledge. Does this sound familiar? We
have been hearing about the golden age
cosmic egg. If you've been watching our
channel, please go watch that particular
show. The new age, the occult has been
looking for this period of time to come
for a long time. in what they also call
the new world order. So this was the
Nazis. They were looking for this time
period to come about. And after World
War II, these same tools were picked up
by global media producers, governments,
and intelligence agencies in order to
control people. Edward Bernay, the
father of public relations and nephew of
Sigman Freud, pioneered modern mass
manipulation through desire, fear, and
repetition. He said, "If we understand
the mechanism and motives of the group
mind, it is now possible to control and
regiment the masses according to our
will without them knowing it." This was
the goal behind all of it. Like I'm
saying from the Nazis standpoint, their
influence onto modernday networks, the
way our society works today. This is how
people from many cultures and different
backgrounds are being unified into one
culture today by appealing not to truth
but to their universal fallen nature of
man. The lust of the eyes, the lust of
the flesh and the pride of life. Even
though external cultures vary, they all
do. From what we wear, we eat, way we
speak, all these things, a shared
craving for fame, pleasure, and self-
glory is exploited through
entertainment, technology, fashion,
food, and education. And again, this is
why it's called programming. It is
actually social engineering on a global
scale. Very clever, huh? The Bible
doesn't talk much about culture in a
modern sense, but it speaks volumes
about the world, idolatry, and false
unity like we've been speaking of. The
first verse that it has on this is 1
John 2:15 where it says, "Do not love
the world or anything in the world. If
anyone loves the world, the love of the
father is not in him." Because we must
be one with the father and we cannot
come to the father except through Jesus
Christ his son. You have to put those
together. So if you love the world or
anything of the world, you do not have
the father either. You have one of those
missing for sure. The next verse I have
is Revelation 13 and 4 says, "All the
world marveled and followed the beast
and worshiped the beast." This is a
result. We can see it everywhere. Then
there's Revelation 18:4 and it says,
"Come out of her, my people, lest you
share in her sins." So from the tower of
babel to the prophecies of revelation,
we can see the pattern is clear. Mankind
continually tries to unite through pride
and rebellion against God. But in the
end, all nations will be deceived into
one cult system spiritually known as
Babylon. Today we would know it actually
as monism, ecumenicism or the coexist
movement. A single religion ultimately
leading to self- godhood is what the
occult in the new age and those who are
in satanic movements are looking for.
Externalization of the hierarchy and you
to become and realize you can be your
own god basically. And we see many
touting national or cultural pride
today. But the truth is all of it must
be brought to the foot of the cross. The
truth is culture must bow to Christ.
Once we come to Christ, our old ways,
even cultural ones, must be crucified.
We are no longer citizens of an earthly
kingdom or a cultural ethnicity. We are
citizens of heaven and must act like
one. If anyone is in Christ, he is a new
creation. It says, "The old has passed
away." 2 Corinthians 5:17. It also says,
"You are a chosen generation, a royal
priesthood, a holy nation." 1 Peter 2:9.
Now, if you want to follow culture and
these rituals and sacrifices and all of
these things of culture, holidays,
festivals, and so on, you cannot really
claim to be that pure, clean, chosen
generation, royal priesthood, a holy
nation. You have been chosen by God, but
you have not been accepted to remain
pure. We cannot have one foot in the
world, in culture, and one foot somehow
in heaven, in our heavenly Christian
life. The Bible doesn't redeem cultures.
It actually redeems people from them.
This means, now listen, this means
tradition must be laid at the cross and
ethnic pride must be crucified and
replaced with heaven's identity. No
culture, no tradition, no heritage will
be taken into the heavenly kingdom. Only
the culture of heaven will remain. It
says where there is neither Greek nor
Jew, circumcision nor circumcision,
barbarian, cythian, bond or free, but
Christ is all and in all. This means we
are all equal. We are all going to be
the same. There is no culture. There is
no race. None is greater than another
except the Godhead. And if we want to
realize or accept truly our place in
heaven, we have to act now and practice
it today. that means we only practice
our citizenship and the culture of
heaven. So I hope that it's been
enlightening and that this is
motivational for us to let go of these
other things that are standing in the
way usually to cause issues between
others to usually uh stroke our own
pride and ego. We don't need any of that
when we're in heaven. Like I said, Bible
does not justify or redeem culture. It
actually redeems people from it. It
saves them, frees them from it. So I
hope you've liked that. Please let us
know in the comments. Love you guys and
I'll see you later. Candy truth.
[Music]